we have lived world james cartwright
we have lived a new and severe
professional crisis 608 of cellphones active not
only am i reading but i
am also a kind of general cultural product
looking for the middle of the 19th century
there is a workshop that decides to choose it
was not yet there for me to read  a literary one
with the aim of raising its
cultural level then it became generalized
because somehow all the
workshops were interested in this
type of performance
[Music]
kirchner works and wore a campaign
on the web güiza benestar whittington
ourense with eggs and beats from the front and
dim  in formosa magazines and therefore
that
power I usually deal with wright topics that
influence his diary that they do in how to
face the various problems also
on specific dates where there are
historical commemorations where there is a
birthday I always bring you something
related to the dates such as the
person because it broadens their level of
knowledge and open their arms with
generally judges when I finish an
hour to a kind of survey in the
last survey they wanted something of an
adventure genre I proposed several
hours and they chose the last one the mohican
is the one we are currently
going to see
[Music]
I like my work I think  It fulfills a
very important objective, not only from the
cultural point of view, but also
from the point of view of being able to deal with
problems that are presented to no one and
that through reading
we sometimes give them a solution, that there is a proverb the tube
that says that  He threatens to get the website
they allege about the American de la
y
[Music]